heute hat die bundesregierung für die
gasversorgung die alarmstufe ausgerufen
der energie krieg eskaliert was heißt
das für verbraucher und unternehmen kann
die politik helfen wenn die preise in
astronomische höhen steigen müssen im
winter industrie anlagen abgeschaltet
werden und die bürger freren oder kann
man sich dagegen wappnen wir müssen
reden mit diesen gästen
christian lindner
bundesfinanzminister und fdp chef
der spd vorsitzende lars klingbeil
die wirtschaftsweise monika schnitzer
henrike roßbach von der süddeutschen
zeitung
und der chef der bundesnetzagentur
klaus müller sie sind zu gast bei
maybrit illner
und die begrüßte alle gäste herzlich
los gehts liebe zuschauer gas ist knapp
und deshalb leuten nun die alarmglocken
wir haben in deutschland eine störung
der gasversorgung so ist definiert daher
ist es erforderlich
diese alarmstufe auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland denn putin macht ernst noch
bevor wir das wort embargo buchstabieren
konnten
russland dreht den gashahn zu
exportmeister deutschland in
schockstarre
wir haben uns die feuerwehr gespart weil
wir das brandrisiko für vernachlässigbar
gehalten haben und jetzt brennt es
lichterloh
aus der traum friday is for future das
war einmal in einem fernen land mit
wachstum und frieden drumherum denn
zeitenwende sticht klimawende
rückbesinnung wird plötzlich
zukunftspolitik wir müssen getrieben
durch die not des tages jetzt wieder
mehr fossile energien verbrennen wir
sollten auch durchaus in erwägung ziehen
die drei noch verbliebenen
kernkraftwerke in deutschland länger
laufen zu lassen meine sorge ist dass
wir in einigen wochen und monaten eine
sehr besorgniserregende situation haben
könnten und in dieser situation dürfen
wir nicht wählerisch sein
konkret wenn die bundesnetzagentur eine
erhebliche reduzierung des gas imports
feststellt dürfen explodierende
marktpreise ungefiltert an verbraucher
durchgereicht werden
monika schnitzer ist bei uns eine der
wirtschaftsweisen dieses landes für
schnitzer es ist hochinteressant
sie haben noch vor drei wochen vor einem
gas embargo gewarnt also davor dass wir
uns entscheiden
russisches gas nicht mehr zu importieren
jetzt dreht russland selbst den hahn zu
wenigstens zu 60 prozent was befürchten
sie nun zum glück haben wir vier monate
lang noch gas bezogen in einer phase als
schon viele darüber gesprochen haben
dass wir den gas an von uns aus zu
drehen sollten das hat uns geholfen die
gasspeicher dann doch schon ganz schön
zu füllen wir sind jetzt bei knapp 60
prozent vor vier monaten sah das noch
ganz anders aus trotzdem ist natürlich
so wenn jetzt weiter der gas die
gaszufuhr reduziert wird wenn also putin
immer mehr ernst machen sollte dann
werden wir uns warm anziehen müssen
spricht dann müssen wir tatsächlich
alles tun um selbst mehr gas zu sparen
bekommen wir also zu einer inflation die
wir jetzt schon haben und spüren eine
rezession einen wirtschaftlichen
abschwung nun wir sehen ja jetzt schon
dass durch die gestiegenen energiepreise
der wirtschaftliche aufschwung den wir
eigentlich hätten erleben sollen und
auch erwarten konnten nach der pandemie
dass der zurückgedrängt worden ist wir
hatten als sachverständigenrat unsere
prognose für dieses jahr unsere
wachstumsprognose von über 4 prozent auf
unter zwei prozent reduziert einfach
deswegen weil die energiepreise so stark
gestiegen sind und werden die jetzt
weiter steigen sollten dazu noch
wirklich versorgungs knappheiten kommen
dann müssen wir tatsächlich damit
rechnen dass wir in eine rezession
rutschen ja christian lindner ist bei
uns der bundesfinanzminister herr
lindner sie haben am mittwoch gestern
die menschen dieses landes eingeschworen
auf harte zeiten sie sagen es kommt eine
ernst zu nehmende wirtschaftskrise auf
uns zu oder wir sind in ihr vier
vielleicht fünf jahre der knappheit
liegen vor uns ich würde mal tippen dass
der bürger dass fastabend er würde gerne
wissen wie knapp es wird wie teuer diese
harten jahre werden
das liegt ja auch an uns wir sind ja
nicht nur objekte schicksalhafter
entwicklungen sondern wir können ja auch
handeln und das macht die
bundesregierung
erst dadurch dass wir jetzt gas in
seiner knappheit beschreiben wir haben
darüber
am gestrigen abend intensiv beraten und
dann gemeinsam die entscheidung
getroffen für den heutigen teil den
heutigen tag an stoff damit sind auch
weitere maßnahmen verbunden
beispielsweise hat sich in den
bundeshaushalt des jahres 2022 bereits
15 milliarden euro an garantien
eingeplant die jetzt genutzt werden
damit der deutsche staat die gasspeicher
befüllt das original ich einkaufen kann
das gibt beginnt jetzt gerade das zweite
was wir tun können druck von den preisen
nehmen die inflation reduzieren mit den
mitteln die der staat hat dh
schuldenbremse einhalten das
diskutieren was
kann man tun den dritten punkt noch
sagen gezielt im nächsten jahr
diejenigen entlasten dieses jahr schon
viel gemacht diejenigen entlasten die
besonders unter der inflation den
preissteigerungen bleiben das werden sie
uns nachher noch ein bisschen dieter
erklären es sind dann ausschließlich die
die besonders leiden und dann ist auch
klar definiert welche gruppe und welche
menschen das treffen wird die insgesamt
zu wenig haben die hartz 4 empfänger
oder werden auch die menschen die
arbeiten aber jetzt keine top einkommen
haben leiden ja also ich möchte das
nicht nur auf bezieher von
grundsicherung
reduzieren nur eines muss klar sein bei
gestiegenen preisen insgesamt ist der
staat nicht in der lage auf dauer
dagegen an subventionieren zu können die
fiskalischen möglichkeiten selbst
deutschlands sind begrenzt oder in
anderen worten sagen wir können uns
zusätzliche schulden nicht mehr leisten
weil wir inzwischen enorme zinsen auch
im staat zahle nicht nur eine zahl x
erwähnen im letzten jahr hat der staat
vier milliarden euro für seine zinsen
gezahlt im nächsten jahr plane ich
bereits 30 1 wir können also die politik
auf pump nicht fortsetzen sie
sind auf der linken seite mit henrike
roßbach nicht ausgestattet aber sie
sitzt neben ihnen journalisten ob büro
der süddeutschen zeitung ökonomischer
selbstmord von rosbach sozialer friede
in gefahr katastrophaler zusammenbruch
das klingt alles nicht so als würde
diese gasknappheit putin mehr schaden
als uns
also wie das am ende ausgeht das kann
man jetzt noch nicht sagen aber tatsache
ist dass natürlich dass uns jetzt schon
schadet und in den nächsten monaten und
womöglich jahren massiv schaden wird
aber es gibt natürlich kaum eine
alternative wir können nicht so tun als
wäre putin nicht in der ukraine
einmarschiert und als würden wir jetzt
kein problem weiter von ihm gas zu
beziehen das ist ja keine möglichkeit
also so hart es ist und so schwer das
ist man kann nur versuchen mit den
gegebenen bedingungen umzugehen als land
denn das was worauf putin abzielt also
freiheitliche demokratien zu bekämpfen
und und die friedensordnung zu
erschüttern und grenzen neu zu ziehen
das kann man ja nicht mit blick auf die
gasrechnung dann sagen na gut das müssen
wir jetzt hinnehmen ist das dürfen wir
nicht hinnehmen glaube ich werde die
schäden die dann entstehen würden die
werden natürlich noch viel größer damit
würde man ja kaputt machen was man in
den jahrzehnten seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg in europa aufgebaut lars
klingbeil spd parteivorsitzender klingt
weil sie haben am dienstag eine
programmatische rede gehalten und unter
anderem die führungsmacht deutschland in
aussicht gestellt die linke kritisiert
sie heute und sagt sie sollten nicht
deutschland ins zentrum europas stellen
sondern sie sollten endlich den bürger
wieder ins zentrum ihrer politik stellen
die frage ist einfach kann und wie sehr
muss diese bundesregierung morgen und
übermorgen über die entlassungs pakete
hinausgehen die jetzt auf dem tisch
liegen für 22 okay das war jetzt ein
paar sachen zusammen beim erstmal finde
ich es richtig wenn deutschland führung
übernimmt ich denn mal nur das beispiel
des kandidatenstatus der ukraine das
wurde heute entschieden das war richtig
dass olaf scholz für die bundesregierung
der vorangegangen ist und das 27 staaten
die jetzt gefolgt sind das ist eine
führung
wünsche und das ist gut die bürgerinnen
und bürger christian lindner hat das
beschrieben haben wir in zwei
koalitionsbeschlüssen sehr klar den
mittelpunkt gestellt wir haben über 30
milliarden in die hand genommen wir
haben angefangen zu entlasten wir federn
ab was diese krisen und das sind sehr
vielfältige krisen was die gerade für
das land für die bürgerinnen und bürger
bedeuten und ich will ein aspekt nochmal
aufgreifen dem fenster gerade gesagt hat
wir haben ja gekämpft wir als partei
aber auch die regierung dass wir nicht
zu dem gas embargo kommen wir haben viel
kritik dafür eingesteckt wie ich
erinnere daran dass ich hier mit
friedrich merz gesessen habt ihr ganz
einfach mal der satz fiel dann drehen
wir doch nord stream 1 ab heute sind wir
froh dass wir über vier monate sie haben
es gerade beschrieben dass wir die
gastanks gefüllt haben dass wir heute 60
prozent erreicht haben aber das zeigt
auch das ist richtig war von der
bundesregierung dass wir den zweiten und
den dritten und dem vierten schritt mit
gedacht haben und immer gefragt haben
was heißt das eigentlich in der
konsequenz viele haben ja gedacht wir
können uns solidarisch an die seite der
ukraine stellen und das hat keine
auswirkungen für uns und ich finde
richtig dass wir solidarisch an der
seite der ukraine stehen und das tun wir
auch sehr klar aber visier nimmt auch es
passiert etwas bei uns und wir müssen
unser vater monaten still dinge hängen
zusammen klaus müller ist bei uns er ist
zugeschaltet aus band der präsident der
bundesnetzagentur einen guten abend nach
bonn herr müller sie haben heute
insgesamt einen aufregenden tag und
natürlich einen mit vielen interviews es
ist entschieden worden durch die
bundesregierung die erhöhten preise noch
nicht an die verbraucher weiterzugeben
das ist zu erklären mit dem § 24 sagen
sie uns noch mal warum sie es nicht
getan haben
weil die jetzige lage noch nicht so ist
dass die bundesnetzagentur tatsächlich
von einer substanziellen reduktion der
gas flüsse reden würde wir wollen das
über mehrere tage hinweg beobachten es
gibt ja immerhin auch die chance auch
wenn sie unwahrscheinlich ist dass putin
die gasfluss über nord stream 1 wieder
erhöhen würde umgekehrt wir wissen dass
es eine jährliche wartung von nord
stream 1 gibt dass es in anderen jahren
nie eine überraschung gar keine
nachricht gewesen aber ab dem 11 juli
rechnen wir erst mal damit dass die gas
flüsse über diese leitung auf null
runter gehen insofern beobachten wie die
situation und das instrument was sie
erwähnt haben hätte ja drastische
konsequenzen über die preissteigerung
die es jetzt ja schon gegeben hat dass
sie die preissteigerung der letzten
monate themen noch mal eine große
schippe obendrauf das wir sehr sehr gut
abgewogen und überlegt sein die
bundesregierung hat die versorger die
energieversorger im grunde schon in der
tür mussten sie sich auch entscheiden ob
sie jetzt stadtwerke pleite gehen lassen
oder heben er deren kunden
ein stand heute geht es nicht darum dass
stadtwerke oder jemand anders pleitegeht
stand heute haben wir noch eine stabile
versorgung mit gas auf niedrigem niveau
perspektivisch auf zu niedrigem niveau
daum sprechen wir von einer angespannten
lage darum heute morgen die entscheidung
für die alarmstufe an der stelle die
bundesnetzagentur hat verschiedene
szenarien durchgerechnet unter
verschiedenen umständen wie sich
richtung herbst und winter die
gasspeicher entwickeln würden und wir
sind eben da zum ergebnis gekommen
abhängig von dem was herr putin
entscheidet abhängig davon wie wir
selber in der industrie bei den privaten
verbrauchern gas einsparen gibt es
unterschiedliche ergebnisse und die
haben uns nicht glücklich gemacht aber
daraus muss man jetzt eben weitere
aktivitäten entwickeln wir werden
sicherlich nachher über die kohle
gasverstromung reden wir werden darüber
reden wie herr lindner zurecht erwähnt
hat dass wir gas zu kaufen können das
flüssiggas terminals auf dem weg an die
deutsche nordseeküste sind erhält das
sind aktivitäten die wichtig sind sie
können momentan reden wir darüber die
gas notlage oder knappheiten zu
vermeiden sie können mit dieser
alarmstufe muss man auch noch mal
erklären jetzt beginnen kohlekraftwerke
wieder zu nutzen sie haben diesen elf
siebter erwähnt der findet von nord
stream 1 eben eine zehntägige wartung
stadt glaube ich und das heißt sie
vermuten jetzt nur dass dann das gas
wieder kommt oder
vermuten dass es nicht kommen das ist
ein blick in die schneekugel verstehe
ich das richtig
das ist vollkommen richtig die berühmte
glaskugel was wir allerdings wissen
gehört und analysiert haben ist die rede
von präsident putin von vergangenem
freitag und ich befürchte irgendwann mal
werden historiker diese rede als sehr
sehr einschneidend einstufen weil in
dieser rede putin im prinzip die
jahrzehntelange beziehung aufgekündigt
hat russland hat über jahrzehnte hinweg
im kalten krieg in allen krisen
zuverlässig verträge erfüllt und gas
geliefert wurde der esel freitag hoch
offiziell aufgekündigt
genau hoch offiziell aufgekündigt und
darum darf man leider sehr sehr besorgt
sein was nach der wartung passiert alles
ist möglich ein hochfahren auf hundert
in eine fortsetzung auf den 40 prozent
die wir heute haben aber leider auch
düstere szenario frau rosberg die
verbraucherzentralen rechnen jetzt für
eine dreiköpfige familie schon
preissteigerungen bis zu 20.000 euro
nachzahlungen allein für gas aus wenn es
jetzt 20.000 euro 2000 was hab ich
gesagt habe doch 2000 nachzahlungen für
gas pardon
wenn jetzt tatsächlich eine weitere
preissteigerung noch aus und was macht
man dann brauchen wir dann 13 gehalt
sparen wir den sommerurlaub
also
wirklich bedürftigen haushalten demos
auf jeden fall der staat natürlich
helfen das ist jetzt schon das erste mal
passiert mit dem heizkostenzuschuss aber
dann wird mit sicherheit durch anpassung
der grundsicherungs setzte an das
existenzminimum et cetera wird das ja
auch passieren für alle anderen sind es
natürlich aber auch starke belastungen
ja das ist natürlich völlig klar und ja
das wird sich negativ auf den konsum
auswirken manche familien werden eben
dann wirklich überlegen ob sie sich
diese oder jene urlaubsreise leisten
können raten kann man ja nur den leuten
dass sie versuchen energie zu sparen wo
das eben geht und dass man versucht
schon mal geld zurückzulegen dass man
vielleicht die nebenkosten
vorauszahlungen erhöht freiwillig damit
am schluss nicht so viel zusammenkommt
aber es gibt natürlich eine menge
familien und und und und konstellationen
im land wo das eher schwierig ist weil
einfach jetzt der puffer nicht besonders
groß ist um jetzt für die gasrechnung in
zehn monaten schon rücklagen große
rücklagen zu bilden ja es wird das da
kommt ja dann auch die rezession unter
anderem her es ist ja klar also dass wir
für energie zahlen können wir dann für
andere dinge nicht mehr ausgeben und das
ist natürlich auch teil des problems
müssen wir herr müller können sie uns
noch mehr helfen beim beschreiben
menschen die mit öl oder strom heizen
die haben dieses problemen in bezug auf
das glas jetzt nicht und leiden in
anführungsstrichen nur unter der irland
inflation
naja die inflation ist ja maßgeblich
insgesamt energiepreis getrieben und wir
haben auch im strombereich
preissteigerungen gesehen wir haben im
ölbereich preissteigerung gesehen das
hat auch in gewissem sinne etwas mit den
öl embargos zu tun gegenüber russland
das hat insgesamt natürlich auch preise
getrieben beim gas sind natürlich die
preissprünge am extremsten auch ich gebe
ihnen eine zahl vor der krise hatten wir
ungefähr ein niveau von 20 euro den
kubikmeter gas wenn wir jetzt in die
gasbörse von heute gucken dann liegen
wir bei über 130 euro das eine
versechsfachung das kommt nicht eins zu
eins bei den privaten haushalten an da
gibt es eine reihe von dämpfenden
faktoren aber zum beispiel in der
industrie bei gewerbekunden und
abgeschwächt eben auch bei privaten
haushalten wird das in den nächsten
monaten und im nächsten jahr
durchschlagen das sind schon ganz ganz
gravierender preissprünge und das geld
geben unter anderem nach russland dass
es keine befriedigende situation wie
können noch eine letzte verbraucher
frage an der stelle wie können sich
verbraucher dann auf die nächste stufe
also auf die notfall stufe vorbereiten
wenn das gas wirklich fehlt und
vollständig fehlt gas haben es dann kann
man ja nicht
das ist vollkommen richtig und in der
notfall stufe wenn sie denn käme wo wir
heute noch nicht sind dann würde
europäisches recht greifen es gibt eine
europäische schutzverordnung die
bedeutet und besagt dass besonders
schutzwürdige gruppen das sind
krankenhäuser pflegeheime kasernen aber
eben auch private haushalte dass hier
die bundesnetzagentur die dann eine
besondere aufgabe hätte nämlich über zu
knappes gas auch in der zuteilung mit zu
entscheiden er dass diese gruppen
besonders geschützt werden das heißt wir
müssten bei anderen industriekunden
zuerst entscheidungen treffen die in den
konsequenzen schrecklich und ein
steigend wären aber wir würden private
haushalte so lange schützen die das
irgendwie möglich wäre und dank der
zuflüsse aus norwegen holland aus
belgien den lng terminals den
schwimmenden die wir heranschaffen der
umstellung von kohle auch ein von gas
aus kohlekraftwerken die ich davon aus
dass uns das auch gelingen müsste aber
für industrie wäre das womöglich ein
sehr sehr furchtbare szenario darum
nochmal wir können jetzt alles dazu
beitragen um das zu vermeiden
man muss ja fast sagen frieren für den
frieden klingt fast noch harmlos wenn es
jetzt also auch dazu geht das ganze
branchen in der industrie
notfallpläne erarbeiten wir haben einen
mangel an material wir haben einen
mangel an arbeitskräften einem mangel an
energie das ist eine nicht gekannte
situation ist das so das ist eine nicht
gekannte situation meine hauptsorge sind
aber vor allen dingen die menschen die
nicht wissen wie sie ihr leben
finanzieren sollen und ich sage ganz
offen ich habe große sorgen das hält
mich mitunter nachts aufwacht aber diese
große sorge muss gleichzeitig zu großer
konzentration
führen damit wir jetzt das richtige tun
und entscheidenden zwei dinge muss man
ja voneinander trennen es gibt
ökonomische und physikalische folgen
ökonomisch steigende preise deshalb
müssen wir entlasten sie haben gerade
die preissteigerungen genannt eine
vierköpfige familie beide arbeiten zwei
kinder die haben wir allerdings bereits
für dieses jahr entlastet mit über 1000
euro im monat muss man auch sagen wir
haben wirtschaftshilfen für die
unternehmen sie haben über stadtwerke
gesprochen die in schwierigkeiten
geraten könnten wir haben gerade die
gazprom germania gesellschaft staatlich
auch gestützt so dass es nicht einen
effekt kommt wie damals bei der lehman
bank vor zehn jahren und zum anderen
haben wir die physikalische knappheit
die wir befürchten deshalb er jetzt die
alarmstufe und auf die bereiten wir uns
schon länger vor freuen wir bezahlen die
schon angesprochenen lng terminals das
sind also schiffe die ankommen das
flüssiggas so um arbeiten dass es in
unserer pipeline es verteilt werden kann
wir beschleunigen die verfahren bei der
erneuerbaren energie bei uns wir
versuchen ansonsten auch zu
diversifizieren jetzt werden die
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve geholt
was ich übrigens auch nicht
als eine geniale eine trivialität
betrachtet denn wir haben ja auch
ambitionierte klimaziele und ich möchte
noch weitergehen weil wir eine so
kritische situation haben die nächsten
drei bis fünf jahre ich hoffe es ist
weniger kurz aber mindestens bei den
weniger lang entschuldigung aber
mindestens bei den preisen wird es eine
zeit noch noch dauern ich meine wir
dürfen uns keine tabus erlauben für mich
heißt das wir wollen alle grünen
wasserstoff nach deutschland importieren
das meinte ich eben im einspieler mit
nicht wählerisch sein ich bin auch
bereit roten wasserstoff aus frankreich
einzukaufen also den wasserstoff der mit
kernenergie gemacht worden ist und ich
wäre auch bereit für eine diskussion in
deutschland unsere verbliebenen
kernkraftwerke eine zeit weiter zu
verwenden um alles zu nutzen um preise
zu reduzieren wir kommen zu dieser
atomdiskussion auf jeden fall noch ich
würde gern noch in fragen wollen vorher
ob sie möglichkeiten sehen wo der staat
auch sparen kann also die aufforderung
dass der bürger sparen soll die iss im
raum wir sollen uns von den
abgedichteten fenstern bis irgendwie zu
den thermostaten für die heizung
möglichst neue dinge anschaffen gibt es
aus ihrer sicht auch dinge die wo der
staat in einen sparmodus gehen kann und
sagen können wir können auch in unseren
ministerien und an anderen stellen
energie sparen machen sie das im
finanzministerium natürlich können wir
auch beim start energie sparen indem
beispielsweise die energetische
sanierung der gebäude voran getrieben
wird das braucht aber zeit das ist
nichts was adhoc funktioniert also
insofern
ich glaube die aufgabe des staates ist
jetzt eher eine andere nämlich die
energieversorgung die versorgung
beispielsweise auch mit gas
sicherzustellen auf der anderen seite
dafür zu sorgen dass die menschen ihr
leben führen können und dafür zu sorgen
dass wir keine wirtschaftliche struktur
krise bekommen wie sie drohen könnte
wenn wir nicht die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen so und damit sind
wir in ihrer koalition in ihrer fraktion
herr klingbeil da ist heute moniert
worden von den kollegen dass die zu
wenig vorsorge getroffen ist dass es zu
energiesparen kommt dass mieter nicht
geschützt werden in einer situation wenn
dann plötzlich der gashahn abgestellt
wird genauso wird gewarnt davor dass man
unternehmen nicht in die pleite gehen
lässt ihre kollegen in der fraktion sind
hoch besorgt sind sie das vielleicht
weil jeder bürger ist ich glaube wir
sind alle besorgt also das war gestern
das darf ich glaube ich verraten das war
gestern noch im koalitionsausschuss das
war sehr ernst und wir wissen in welche
ernst der lage sind wir sind jetzt immer
noch in dem moment wo wir handeln können
deswegen ist es glaube ich eine
nationale kraftanstrengung dass politik
das unternehmen das alle sich fragen wo
können wir sparen was können wir
gemeinsam tun das wichtigste ist jetzt
dass die speicher gefüllt werden daran
müssen wir arbeiten
es ist wichtig dass alternativen
aufgebaut werden wir gucken dass wir
beim lg christian linder das
angesprochen dass wir das schneller
vorankommen als eigentlich geplant wir
müssen beschleunigen in der frage der
erneuerbaren energien also das muss
alles passieren und gleichzeitig
brauchen die bürgerinnen und bürger aber
eine gewissheit dass zum beispiel
niemand seine wohnung verliert weil er
die nächsten monate die energiekosten
nicht tragen kann und das ist ein
schutzschirm den wir vorschlagen den
willen der koalition noch diskutieren
wollen für die mieterinnen und mieter
und das ist erst mal wichtig für die
menschen die auch glaube ich bereit sind
energie zu sparen die sich darum kümmern
die gerade den ernst der lage erkennen
also ich glaube überall wird gerade zu
hause diskutiert was können wir tun um
energie zu sparen aber es muss auch eine
gewissheit geben eine verlässlichkeit
geben dass niemand seine wohnung
verliert aufgrund der steigenden
energiepreise wir fragen noch mal die
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin
was würden sie denken ist jetzt das was
der bürger tun kann und was müsste die
politik als erstes tun in der situation
in der wir sind ja ich glaube man muss
tatsächlich den menschen die richtigen
signale gegeben das passiert ist gerade
mit dieser alarmstufe einerseits durch
den preis der preis wird steigen wenn er
jetzt schon steigen würde würde man es
sofort merken die menschen müssen sofort
reagieren auch durch entsprechende
appelle also ich muss mir als bürgerin
überlegen was kann ich denn tun um gas
einzusparen und da kann man natürlich an
energiesparmaßnahmen denken an
energetische sanierung das geht war
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schnell wir
haben da nicht das material nicht die
die kräfte um das einzubauen und dann
schauen wir mal auf ein beispiel zurück
in den 70er jahren als in japan man
überlegt hat wie geht mit der
ölpreiskrise und dann hat man sehr
pragmatisch agiert man hat zum beispiel
heizungsrohre im keller
umwickelt um einfach diese dämmung
selbst und zu nehmen das heißt man hat
sehr pragmatisch solche dinge gemacht
man hat in den unternehmen gesagt one up
down ich gehe eine treppe hoch wenn ich
ins nächste stockwerk will ich gehe zwei
treppen runter dafür benutze ich keinen
aufzug also solche maßnahmen würden
helfen und das ist übrigens auch für die
unternehmen natürlich jetzt genau die
das gebot der stunde dafür würden dann
auch dinge helfen wie jetzt vorgesehen
ist gas auktionsmodell also die
unternehmen zu fragen wer kann auf gas
verzichten wer ist bereit für dies so
viel geld das zu tun um das dann ein zu
speichern das heißt einerseits magische
elemente tatsächlich preise wirken
lassen und dafür kompensieren und
gleichzeitig aber auch appelle die für
manche menschen dann tatsächlich auch
das etwas was sie motiviert one up down
ein solcher spruch und in japan ist er
inzwischen in der dna verankert
er hat sich dazu schon geäußert also
duschköpfe sollen wir wechseln weil man
da auch sparen kann die thermostate
sollen bearbeiten aber mit dem gedanken
gegenwärtig haben wir noch keine strom
note geben er könne doch gehören auch
keine lücke beim gas haben wir eine
knappheit und deshalb ist das erste
gebot kein gas mehr einsetzen um strom
zu produzieren ganz genau das ist das
allererste wir brauchen das gas zum
heizen im winter
wir brauchen das gas bei bestimmten
industriellen prozessen warum passiert
das erst jetzt der linden entschuldigen
man hätte ja sofort sagen können es ist
das also gras ist teuer sehr sehr
wertvoll und wie wir sehen jetzt auch
knapp warum passiert es erst jetzt zu
sagen wir sollten es auf gar keinen fall
weiter zur stromproduktion verwendet
ja wir sind schon länger dabei diese
diese knappheit zu bearbeiten
nun wir sehen jetzt ja die konsequenzen
des ukraine kriegs und der russischen
politik noch sehr viel klarer und warum
sind die gasspeicher in deutschland
jetzt so gut gefüllt weil wir natürlich
schon damit gearbeitet haben mit diesen
knappheiten und sie bewirtschaftet haben
nur jetzt ist die situation noch mal
ernster und deshalb mein appell gas
brauchen wir für anderes als für die
produktion von strom hat übrigens noch
einen nebeneffekt die gaskraftwerke sind
in deutschland die teuersten das sind
die letzten die angeschaltet werden und
dann bestimmt der preis des
gaskraftwerks die gesamten energiepreise
die gesamten strompreise das heißt die
produzenten von solar und windenergie
machen sehr hohe gewinne gegenwärtig
weil der gaspreis das beeinflusst und
sofern raus mit dem gas kraftwerken aus
der stille und sicherer heizung wir
brauchen sie für die produktion und land
braucht es sogar als lebensnotwendigen
stoff weil wir industriegase ja auch für
die chemische industrie natürlich es
gibt bestimmte produktion die gehen nur
mit gas und wenn da kein gas mehr ist
steht das still jetzt kommt das wie ich
finde sehr kritische wenn bestimmte
anlagen einmal ganz runter gefahren
werden bei gas fehlt sind sie kaputt und
dann werden sie in deutschland nicht neu
aufgebaut sondern dann wird neu im
ausland in asien investiert und das ist
die die strukturkrise die drohen kann
durch die gas knapp hat die wir
unbedingt im interesse unseres
wohlstands des jahres 2030 abwenden
müssen herr russwurm hat hier in der
sendung unter anderem von der komik
industrie erzählt so eine keramik fahne
wenn die einmal kalt wird dann ist sie
eben glass naja das heißt wir können
vielleicht die pillen noch herstellen
aber es wird schwierig den glasbehälter
herzustellen indem die pillen sind herr
müller sie haben das vorhin schon
angedeutet wenn diese lieferungen von
gas morgen stoppen was wir alle nicht
hoffen aber auch das ist ja eben ein
szenario mit dem sie rechnen müssen nach
welchen kriterien entscheiden sie dann
wär
lebensnotwendig ist und weiter arbeiten
und wirtschaften darf und wer nicht
also erstmal mussten wir feststellen
dass für das szenario was sie
beschreiben was ja eine entscheidung der
bundesregierung voraussetzen würde
nämlich die dritte stufe die gas notlage
auszurufen dass die bundesnetzagentur
für diese situation nicht wirklich gut
vorbereitet war darum haben wir
unmittelbar anfang märz damit begonnen
gemeinsam mit dem bdi und bda aus den
verbänden der energiewirtschaft und der
industrie zu sagen wo ziehen wir dann
eine grenze wo unternehmen dann
punktuelle entscheidungen von uns
bekommen und welche kriterien welche
informationen muss die bundesnetzagentur
haben und das entscheiden zu können das
haben wir mit den beiden verbänden und
dem bundeswirtschaftsministerium
abgestimmt wir haben dann unmittelbar
begonnen eine it plattform zu
programmieren wir haben ein bisschen
sage ich mal aus der analogen
entscheidungs welt von corona gelernt
solche künftigen entscheidungen müssen
digital ablaufen sowohl vom
informationsfluss der industrie
gegenüber der bundesnetzagentur wie auch
umgekehrt das problem ist nur solche
projekte brauchen zeit sie müssen auch
sehr sicher sein ich möchte keinen
erfolgreichen hackerangriff gegen eine
solche entscheidung plattform erleben
und sobald diese plattform steht was
morgen noch nicht leider der fall sein
wird dann können wir die lieferketten
verstehen dann können wir den
betriebswirtschaftlichen und
volkswirtschaftlichen schaden verstehen
die auswirkungen dies hat und dann
werden wir versuchen eine entscheidung
zu treffen die diese negativen effekte
minimiert hängen aber natürlich davon ab
wie viel gas haben wir dann in den
speichern und wie viel bekommen wir so
und wenn wir es uns gelänge diesen
gasspeicher bis zum herbst zu füllen
dann kämen wir damit über einen winter
nämlich über den dann nächstfolgenden
da schüttelt er den kopf nein leider
nicht um ihn ein gefühl zu während die
speicher in deutschland rechnerisch zu
100 prozent gefüllt er wir noch ein
gutes stück weit entfernt sind und
würden wir einen durchschnittlichen
winter erleben also die jetzt wieder
besonders warm oder kalt wäre dann
könnten wir bei einem vollkommenen
verzicht auf russisches gas durch an
putins entscheidung zb gerade mal
zweieinhalb monate uns versorgen und
dann werden die speicher leer
europäische nachbarländer mit ihren
interessen sind dabei noch gar nicht
berücksichtigt das heißt die speicher
sind existenziell aber zweieinhalb
monate lange winter habe ich selten
erlebt und insofern müssen wir eben noch
mehr tun wir müssen ihm zusätzliches gas
bekommen darwin haben herr lindner und
der klingen bei leben hingewiesen ganz
entscheidend und wir müssen ihm
einsparen wir müssen ein spannend
zusätzlich einkaufen und wann wird aus
dieser knappheit dann ein mangel der sie
dazu führt auch einzelne branchen oder
eben einzelne unternehmen zunächst vom
gas zu nehmen
das wäre dann der fall wenn wir in einer
dritten stufe die die bundesregierung zu
entscheiden hätte tatsächlich einen ganz
realen mangel hätten stand heute sind
wir besorgt die situation ist angespannt
sehr angespannt aber wir bekommen noch
gas wir können sogar gas einspeichern
die zahlen von heute morgen waren 0,3
prozentpunkte wir ein gespeichert haben
das liegt etwas unter dem durchschnitt
der letzten wochen aber noch fließt gas
das ist aber eine situation im sommer im
sommer heizen die menschen nicht und wir
haben gesehen dass die industrie auch
schon teilweise reduziert hat noch nicht
genug aber sie haben reduziert aber der
sommer dauert noch ungefähr drei monate
in drei monaten beginnt die heizsaison
und darum hat die bundesregierung
entschieden heute die alarmstufe
auszurufen bei all die maßnahmen die wir
gerade schon gehört haben optimierung
der heizung vorbereitung auf weitere
spanier haßmann brauchen zeit damit wir
dann im herz nicht erst anfang hektisch
zu werden verkaufen sich in europa jetzt
die nachbarn gegenseitig diese
gasreserven weg das europa das so
zusammenwachsende das ist natürlich
genau das problem wo kommt das gas denn
eigentlich her wir haben in europa
gasvorkommen ganz vieles kommt natürlich
von außerhalb europas
übrigens zurzeit mehr weil der gaspreis
so gestiegen ist also die gestiegene
gaspreise hat dazu geführt dass amerika
zum beispiel jetzt mehr gas zu uns
liefern wie wir das jetzt in europa
verteilen das sollte auch politisch
abgestimmt werden also an der stelle ist
natürlich solidarität gefragt das kann
nicht sein dass wir uns da gegenseitig
konkurrenz machen aber in der tat wir
sind alle daran interessiert möglichst
viel von außerhalb europas auch hierher
zu bekommen das heißt es besteht aber
die gefahr dass am ende jedes land für
sich alleine friert im winter
am ende müssen wir uns überlegen wie wir
es am besten lenken in die einzelnen
länder da wird natürlich wieder auch der
markt nur eine rolle spielen wer hat die
besten möglichkeiten auch zu
substituieren also wer kann zum beispiel
in frankreich brauche ich kein gas für
für strom wer kann also mit anderen
maßnahmen gut zurechtkommen und da ist
immer der preis das beste instrument um
das zu lenken und zu lange her klingt es
hängt eben alles mit allem zusammen ist
das ziel nie wieder gas und öl aus
russland zu kaufen
also ein nie wieder würde mir schwer
fallen weil ich nicht weiß wie die
entwicklung sein wird aber putin strich
sind jemanden vollständige
unabhängigkeit
das ist das ziel das ist übrigens im
koalitionsvertrag den wirt ampel
geschlossen haben angelegt dass wir
deutschland modernisieren wollen dass
wir deutschland in der energieversorgung
neu aufstellen wollen dass wir den weg
der erneuerbaren sehr konsequent gehen
und diese dringlichkeit die wir im
koalitionsvertrag ja schon festgehalten
haben die hat sich durch putins kriegt
noch mal gesteigert ich frage bewusst
vollständige unabhängigkeit
nicht mehr angewiesen sein auf öl und
gas aus russland oder würden sie sich
auch da gerne eine tür offen halten nein
ich glaube wenn wir den weg gehen
komplett auf die erneuerbaren zu setzen
wenn wir als deutschland das land sind
dass das schafft das auf innovation auf
neue technologien auf neue
geschäftsmodelle setzt dann ist das ja
auch etwas wo sich viele andere länder
daran orientieren werden wo wir zeigen
dieser weg geht und ich finde dass die
jetzige situation noch mal konsequenter
die notwendigkeit zeigt und mein ziel
ist das völlig wegzukommen von der
abhängig von russland ich will jetzt
zwei dinge trennen einmal ganz kurz wie
dramatisch ist es aus ihrer sicht dass
wir so abhängig sind von putin dass wir
nun sogar auf diesen siebten schauen um
dann zu wissen ob zu 60 oder zu 70 oder
zu 80 prozent kein gas mehr fließt und
ganze industriebranchen hier wegbrechen
können also das ist dramatisch und da
haben wir auch fehler gemacht in der
vergangenen legislatur in den
vergangenen legislatur aber nochmal der
koalitionsvertrag den winamp geschossen
haben wir ja genau angelegt diese fehler
auch zu korrigieren und sehr konsequent
den weg in das erneuerbare zeitalter zu
gehen also in bezug auf russland will
ich einen
kritischen gedanken äußern aber ich
glaube das muss auch einmal gesagt
werden am 8 mai 1945 ist nazi
deutschland befreit worden durch die
alliierten
aber deutschland ist danach in die
internationale gemeinschaft
zurückgekehrt und deshalb würde ich
aussagen in bezug auf russland eines nie
wieder nicht unterschreiben jeden
sonntagabend erinnere ich an alexej
nawalny einen liberalen oppositionellen
russland ist anders als oder ist nicht
gleich putin und deshalb nie wieder in
bezug auf russland halten sonst kann man
ja auch eine tage die fach und schnaps
an hat sich einfach so eingebürgert dass
er sonntags abends daran erinnere er ist
diese oppositionelle der anschlag
überlebt hat dort in haft ist sich er
ist stellvertretend auch für eine andere
position er dies dann noch gibt also
insofern muss man die die generelle
putin ordnete rissen und ist nicht das
russische volk so ist es elvis und die
andere frage ist die der
energieversorgung und die hat lars
klingbeil völlig recht deutschland hat
eben den vergangenen jahrzehnten den
großen fehler gemacht dass wir uns nicht
global aufgestellt haben sondern oft
bilateral unsere sicherheit die haben
wir an die amerikaner ausgesetzt
unsere energieversorgung aus russland
und im übrigen haben wir eine sehr hohe
abhängigkeit vom chinesischen
binnenmarkt und das nennen wir teuer
verkaufen wollen oder das müssen wir
überwinden deshalb haben wir jetzt als
ampel koalition entschieden
das freihandelsabkommen mit kanada zu
ratifizieren weitere solche abkommen
müssen kommen damit wir uns weltweit
auch dort vielfältige aufstellen
energieversorgung der arbeiten wir an
unseren eigenen möglichkeiten bei den
erneuerbaren energien übrigens ich wäre
auch offen für die exploration also die
suche nach öl und gasquellen in der
nordsee da sind nämlich noch welches ja
gesagt die sind heute auch
wirtschaftlicher als früher zu anderen
preisen und das ist der weg den wir
gehen hier reden die gleich über kohle
und atom und die alternativen energien
dazu und die alten zu denen wir
zurückkehren die opposition heißt heute
cdu csu unter anderem und die
oppositionsführung macht den vorschlag
dass mit einem prozent inflation der
bundesfinanzminister zehn milliarden
annimmt und man diese zehn milliarden
dem bürger zurückgeben könnte dass die
kalte progression um 13 milliarden
wachsen wird und dass der
bundesfinanzminister den bürger doch
einfach auch die kalte progression
zurückgeben könnte was sagt der
bundesfinanzminister
also
dass die
opposition was die zahlen angeht noch
einen weg vor sich hat ihm eine rechnung
die rechnern leider kreative bin ich
jetzt nicht an der opposition arbeiten
soll einfach nur die nüchternen zahlen
der staat gewinnt nicht an der inflation
ich hatte eben schon gesagt dass sie
teurer schulden haben in der tat sehr
ich habe steigende zinsen und es ist
eine steilwand frau illner es ist eine
echte steilwand wir erleben jetzt dass
auch die fiskalischen möglichkeiten
dieses landes begrenzt sind meine erste
priorität ist bekämpfung der inflation
durch solide staatsfinanzen denn wenn
der staat nicht nicht gut mit dem geld
umgeht treibt er die inflation noch an
und im übrigen haben wir das problem
dass wir uns wie ich eben sagte mehr
schulden auch nicht mehr leisten können
das ist anders als in den vergangenen
über zehn jahren da ging es quasi bergab
mit den zinsen pa das geld was man
gespart hat für die zinsen eingesetzt
für was weiß ich und jetzt könnten die
zinsen steigen aber ehrlich gesagt ja
noch also sie steigen durch die ezb noch
gar nicht der spaß
meint der der eben der marktzins selbst
wenn der leitzins nur leicht steigt am
markt stark der zins meine vorgänger
haben
inflationsgesicherte anleihen in den
markt gegeben das bedeutet also es keine
inflation gab hat der staat einen gewinn
gemacht heute kosten diese
inflationsgesicherte anleihen meiner
vorgänger mich im nächsten jahr
milliarden also insofern schulden ist
kein weg das führt nur in mehr inflation
wir müssen zurück zu soliden
staatsfinanzen jetzt kommt der zweite
punkt es gibt einen bereich wo der staat
tatsächlich mehr geld einnimmt das ist
die sogenannte kalte progression das
muss man übersetzen im südwesten
deutschlands bekommen die arbeiter in
der metall und elektroindustrie die
vorarbeiter 6,5 prozent das vielleicht
den kaufkraftverlust aus aber wer
profitiert davon
weil die nämlich in der tabelle des
steuerrechts nach oben rutschen aber das
will sie nicht dabei muss es nicht klein
zeige ich den zuschauern ich weiß wenn
die das gewissen un-mandat und das halte
ich für ungerecht ich halte für
ungerecht dass der staat an den
gehaltserhöhungen mehr profitiert als
die beschäftigten als ich würde da gerne
was ändern in der koalition müssen wir
darüber noch entscheiden das machen wir
im herbst aber meine idee wäre die
gehaltserhöhung sei bei den
beschäftigten also soll bei den
beschäftigten bleiben wir holen noch mal
frau rosbach dazu und fragen ist das ein
wichtig ein wichtiger schritt auch um
den sozialen frieden in diesem land zu
setzen gegen vielleicht eine höhere
kälte in der wohnung naja die einen
sagen so die anderen anders also wenn
die spd oder die grünen die sehen das
glaube ich mit dem ausgleich der kalten
progression ein bisschen anders also da
gibt es ja durchaus stimmen die sagen
das sollte man nur ausgleichen für
untere und mittlere einkommen oder man
sollte es kompensieren den leben dann
höhere einkommen mit einem stärkeren
spitzensteuersatz belastet werden
an der argumentation dass sozusagen das
also der staat ist ja letztlich eine
geheime steuererhöhungen also der stadt
muss nicht sich mit parlamentarischen
prozessen abmühen um die steuern zu
erhöhen sondern sie wachsen einfach so
die steuereinnahmen ohne dass er etwas
macht das ist natürlich in der tat nicht
besonders fair und es gab ja auch in den
vergangenen jahren immer den konsens
dass man das macht das ist richtig das
steht nicht so im koalitionsvertrag aber
es ist klar es gibt diesen bericht dann
können wir das alles sehen und man ist
ja sehr schnell in der höchststufe wenn
man lohnerhöhung ja also ich glaube man
muss glaube ich noch das 1 5-fache des
durchschnittseinkommens zahlen um mit
seinen letzten euros dann sozusagen dem
spitzensteuersatz zu landen und es ist
einfach so dass natürlich so eine so
eine geheime steuererhöhungen also ich
finde dass ich finde das nicht sauber
also wenn der staat die steuern erhöhen
möchte dann soll er das machen mit
seiner mehrheit im bundestag bunt und
transparent naja also herr linder macht
es nicht aber es ist unheimlich zu
machen oder dann zu sagen bei den einen
nehmen wir das mit und bei den anderen
nicht daraus ergibt sich natürlich schon
eine gewisse christian lindner macht ja
gerade den vorschlag daran etwas zu
ändern das ist noch sehr offen vorher
jetzt glaube ich noch ein bisschen
überzeugungsarbeit leisten die hunde die
koalition noch überzeugungsarbeit
leisten also können wir bei herrn klingt
manchmal ganz spontan nachfragen warum
sie julia klöckner hat wenigstens
versucht zu rechnen und sagen bereits
sagt 13 milliarden nehme der staat also
herr lindner durch die kalte progression
einen der staat sei ein inflations
gewinner nächstes jahr nächstes jahr ob
sie herrn lindner helfen möchten das zu
unterbinden also erst mal sind wir uns
einig dass man den facharbeiter der ig
metall aus baden württemberg in den
fokus nehmen muss er hatte leidet unter
der inflation der leitung unter
gestiegenen energiepreisen und nochmal
wir haben zwei entlastungs paket auf den
weg gebracht vieles greift erst aber an
sich lernen beantwortung der frage ist
pd nein wir werden jetzt hier keine
koalitionsverhandlungen führen wir haben
eine neue situation wir haben
dramatische dinge die sich seit
unterzeichnung des koalitionsvertrags
verändert haben aber wir haben vieles im
koalitionsvertrag drin ich glaube ich
dass wir beides nach wie vor für richtig
halten soziale projekte und wir wissen
doch in der koalition auch dass wenn die
wirtschaftliche lage sich weiter so
entwickelt wie sie ist dass wir den
bürgerinnen und bürgern helfen müssen
aber was sie nicht erleben werden ist
dass wir beide hier gegeneinander rennen
bei forderungen sondern wir wissen dass
wir für die bürgerinnen und bürger
verlässlichkeit bieten müssen das haben
wir mit zwei großen paketen in der
koalition jetzt getan und ob wir noch
mehr tun das werden wir dann zusammen in
der koalition entscheiden aber wir sehen
vielleicht noch mal ein kleines
stichwort vierter siebter der gibt es
einen großen gipfel von arbeitgebern und
arbeitnehmern olaf scholz konzertierte
aktion und drei halte ich auch für ganz
sicher sein das halte ich für ganz
wichtig dass olaf scholz diesen
vorschlag gemacht hat dass wir die
politik die gewerkschaften die
arbeitgeber an einen tisch und es ist
eine dramatische situation durch die wir
gemeinsam durchmüssen wir müssen
aufpassen dass in der politik nicht eine
situation haben wir jeden tag irgendwer
einen vorschlag macht sondern dass wir
das ganze bündel an einem tisch dass wir
gucken wie kriegen wir das in der
gemeinsamen kraftanstrengung hin und
dafür ist diese konzertierte aktion in
der dramatischen lage die wir haben
genau das richtige bündeln an einem
tisch ich würde sagen wir versuchen dass
wir gerade schon mal vor schnitzel wenn
man arbeitnehmer arbeitgeber in dieser
konzertierten aktion darauf verständigen
könnte dass es nicht zu hohe
lohnabschlüsse gibt in diesem und im
nächsten jahr um gegebenenfalls dann
eben auch mit mehr geld um ebendiese
lohn preis spirale zu unterbinden um
dann mit mehr geld auch die bürger
entlasten zu können ist es in den augen
einer wirtschaftsweisen ein mögliches
modell ja ich glaube das ist genau das
was passieren muss man muss in einer
solchen konzertierten aktion ich denke
das ist die idee man muss versuchen
gemeinsam an verständnis dabei dafür
über herbeizuführen was ist wirklich die
lage was können wir uns leisten wie
können wir inflation bekämpfen und dazu
muss natürlich beitragen dass die
lohnentwicklung stabilisiert wird aber
das passiert nur dann wenn die
inflationserwartung stabilisiert wird
wenn die arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer
fürchten müssen dass wir
in den nächsten jahren weiterhin ruhe
inflation haben werden dann müssen die
natürlich sich sorgen machen um ihren
real und dann wollen die höhere
lohnforderungen haben das heißt an der
stelle müssen wir schauen wie können wir
das vermeiden wie graewe diese
erwartungen stabilisieren wir können wir
dafür sorgen dass die löhne nicht zu
sehr steigen müssen auf der anderen
seite muss natürlich an der stelle auch
jedes unternehmen sich überlegen was
kann das denn an gewinnen
machen wie viel kann man da noch
tatsächlich rechtfertigen wenn man
seinen eigenen arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer sagt aber für euch haben
wir kein geld also über all diese dinge
muss an der stelle gesprochen werden und
dann natürlich auch was der staat dazu
beitragen kann wenn eben die löhne nicht
so stark steigen wie man den menschen
die hart getroffen sind sie haben es
gesagt wenn man denen helfen muss und
kann der stelle ist noch die frage wie
man es finanziert daher wenn die eine
oder andere steuererhöhungen vielleicht
schon selbst wenn sie durch die kalte
progression gut wir haben und bei denen
bei der frage der steuererhöhungen muss
man im blick behalten wir wollen ja eine
wirtschaftliche entwicklung haben mit
wachstum mit arbeitsplätzen mit
investitionen und das ist die abwägung
vor der der finanzminister steht die
steuer erhöhung bringt mehr geld in die
kasse aber sie hat immer eine auswirkung
auf die wirtschaftliche dynamik gibt es
wachstum werden neue unternehmen
gegründet neue arbeitsplätze geschaffen
also fern das ist nicht trivial
ich glaube auch dass die konzertierte
aktion eine zwingend notwendige
maßnahme ist führt eine familie ist ja
entscheidend was haben wir für ein
haushaltseinkommen was können wir uns
leisten können wir den kühlschrank
füllen gibt es noch eine möglichkeit
vielleicht im sommer urlaub zu machen
das ist für die menschen entscheidend
und wenn jetzt der staat und die
arbeitgeber zusammen arbeiten dann
können wir auch eine gemeinsame lösung
finden mit den instrumenten des staates
und mit dem tarif und
gehaltssteigerungen wie sorgen wir dafür
dass er möglichst viel der kaufkraft der
menschen erhalten füge hinzu dass wir
uns natürlich auch in gedanken machen
müssen um freie berufe und
selbstständige das sind nicht alles top
verdienende unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer sondern gibt es auch solo
selbständige die sind da noch nicht
abgebildet und ich glaube dass wir in
einem nächsten schritt auch spaß wir
müssen mit der kreditwirtschaft
denn es werden nächstes jahr viele
finanzierungen verlängert werden wir
müssen die vermieterinnen und vermieter
an einen tisch holen um auch dort
lösungen zu finden was kann getan werden
damit man sich nicht wechselseitig
überfordert also und das wird eingeladen
sie werden das stets und ständig gefragt
das wollen sie alles schaffen indem sie
trotzdem im nächsten jahr die
schuldenbremse einhalten ich muss ich
kann mir zusätzliche schulden nicht
erlauben wir haben kein geld ich
verwalte das geld der steuerzahlerinnen
und steuerzahler ich habe ja auch die
entwicklung bei den zinsen hingewiesen
machen wir weiter so viel schulden
treiben wir die inflation weiter an man
nennt das expansive finanzpolitik
betreiben die inflation weiter an die
letzten jahre während der pandemie haben
auch eine auswirkung auf die
inflationsentwicklung kommt vor allen
dingen von der energie ja aber das hat
auch eine auswirkung und auf der anderen
seite wenn immer mehr schulden gemacht
werden die zu bezahlen immer teurer ist
dann bist du irgendwann der
notwendigkeit die steuern zu erhöhen
aber nur um die alten schulden zu
bezahlen sieben land strangulieren wir
uns
als regierung und ich glaube das muss
man schon mal aussprechen
expansive finanzpolitik ist natürlich
ein problem wenn man eine hohe inflation
hat aber eigentlich wenn wir
gleichzeitig auch in der
wirtschaftskrise
schlittern ist natürlich eine
restriktive finanzpolitik also dass man
keine hilfen mehr ausreicht dass man
früher oder später vielleicht sogar bei
investitionen sparen muss weil man sorge
hat mit staatlicher investitionen eben
die preise in angespannten märkten wie
bauwirtschaft und so weiter noch stärker
zu
forcieren
also sie kommen da einfach unglaublich
schwieriges gelände ja sie müssen
einerseits müssen die leute entlasten
sie müssen investieren sie müssen aber
auch den staatshaushalt wieder runter
dimmen damit eben nicht diese
zinsentwicklung kommen und rees
zusammenzuführen in dieser
phase das ist ja auch dass das gemeine
an einer gleichzeitigkeit von hoher
inflation und schlechter
wirtschaftlicher entwicklung und der war
so manche beklage mich nicht zu wenig zu
tun zu haben aber es ist jedenfalls
schon also dass jetzt diese konzertierte
aktion also quasi dass das gute zureden
in richtung arbeit arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer als es das dass das kern
also als eine art königsweg jeder als
moros brauche das ich glaube nicht dass
das rad ja aber ich glaube dass sie die
so genannte konzertierte aktion etwas
missverstehen es handelt sich nicht um
gutes zureden sondern es ist schon die
absicht der bundesregierung dass wir
dort mit ideen und maßnahme vorschlägen
auf die tarifpartner zugehen und
vorschläge machen was können wir für
beiträge leisten wir wollen hören was
wird von anderen vorgetragen wir haben
am vierten siebten die erste
konzertierte aktion das erste
gesprächsformat es wird aber nicht das
letzte bleiben sondern in diesem jahr
wird es dann auch weitere gelegenheiten
ergeben bei uns ja auch die krise länger
beschäftigen wird die nur einen satz
noch ergänzen sie haben natürlich
absolut recht bekämpfung der inflation
einerseits und erhalt einer stabilen
wirtschaftlichen perspektive
andererseits verhinderung von
wirtschaftlichen abschwung rezessionen
das ist eine ganz schwierige
abwägungsfrage bei jedem einzelnen
instrument ich will nicht leugnen dass
das enorm schwierig ist und man bei
jeder einzelnen maßnahme lange überlegen
muss was man tut eines kann man aber
sagen branchen wo ist eine ganz große
knappheit gibt denken sie an den
baubereich wo es einen mangel an
materialien gibt es da macht es keinen
sinn dass der staat seine finanzielle
feuerkraft mit subventionen noch genau
dahin lenkt oder denken sie an die
situation bei den elektroautos finde ich
toll großartig denen gehört die zu
korrigieren sollen weg ja weil man kann
die autos noch nicht mal gegenwärtig
ausliefern aufgrund von knappheiten da
macht ja keinen sinn da noch preise zu
subventionieren übrigens verdienen die
autokonzerne milliarden könne nicht den
brauchen sie nicht nach subventionen
muss man nicht noch christian lindner
die steuergroschen aus dem jackett zehn
leute ist nicht mein leben hätte ich
gleich sofort noch dazu sagen müssen es
ist unser aller geld dazu sagt man
steuern finden sie auch das ist unnötig
ist diese kaufprämien bei den e autos
aufrecht zu erhalten hand aufs herz also
wir sehen es funktioniert und es sollte
auslaufen es hat ja schon funktionäre
die nachfragen sind ja da ich glaube wir
brauchen eine klarheit insgesamt das
richtung elektromobilität geht der
konzerne brauchen eine klarheit für
investitionsentscheidungen aber die
prämien haben jetzt eine ganze zeit lang
gewirkt haben die nachfrage angekurbelt
und jetzt ist dann noch mal gut jetzt
ist dann auch mal gut wir sind bei der
entscheidenden frage in den letzten
sechs minuten frei schnitzer atom kohle
sind jetzt die alternativen zu dem
knapper werden denn gas wie viel sinn
macht es in ihren augen auch über atom
nachzudenken wir wissen alle wie sehr
schmerzt die kohlekraftwerke jetzt
wieder ans netz zu holen
ja oder nein
drei atomkraftwerke in deutschland
wieder uns einfach es ist so toll daran
kann über alles nachdenken aber ich bin
da völlig pragmatisch und unideologisch
hätten wir die möglichkeit die laufen zu
lassen ohne irgendwelche schwierigkeiten
würde uns das sicherlich helfen
die experten geben unterschiedliche
einschätzungen dazu wie teuer das ist
wie einfach es ist die brennstoffe
tatsächlich zu bekommen ob das mit
sanktionen belegt ist ob man die
rechtzeitig bekommt wie es mit der
sicherheit ist gerade wenn der vorschlag
im raum steht dass man für fünf jahre
das verlängern sollte da muss man ja
dann noch mal ganz neu investieren in
die sicherheit wenn am ende das heißt
dass der staat dafür
geradestehen muss mitfinanzierung dann
bin ich an der stelle doch etwas
skeptisch dann frage ich mich ob dieses
geld nicht anders besser investiert wäre
wir haben die möglichkeit das mit den
kohlekraftwerken zu machen wir haben
sogar gehört hat sie ja vorhin schon
ausgeführt das macht den strompreis
derzeit sogar günstiger das ist auch
nicht umweltschädlicher insofern als dir
an den zertifikatehandel angebunden sind
das heißt sie müssen dann sei die
fahrkarte kaufen preis geht etwas hoch
andere kaufen es dann weniger also ich
sehe aktuell
nicht dass atomkraft das problem
wirklich lösen muss weil es andere
möglichkeiten gibt aber die experten
sollen sagen wie einfach es ist sagt vor
schnitzer wir sind noch mal in bonn
klaus müller die argumente sind im raum
es betrifft sowieso nur sechs prozent
der energie und die atomenergie ist nur
grundlastfähig aber kann diese spitzen
nicht abdecken was die gaskraftwerke
können was ist ihre position was in ihre
argumente pro atom um alles zu tun was
wir tun müssen ist das ein denkverbot
das richtig ist oder ein denkverbot das
falsch ist
herr lindner hat vorhin einen ganz
wichtigen satz gesagt wir haben keine
stromlücke sondern wir haben ein problem
mit gas an der stelle das ist das
primäre worauf ihr achten müssen
atomkraftwerke produzieren keine wärme
sie heizen keine wohnung sondern sie
produzieren strom und das in der tat
grundlastfähig und darum glaube ich
lassen uns auf das fokussieren was das
problem ist und keine
nebenkriegsschauplätze führen ich werbe
dafür dass wir das problem lösen und ich
glaube dafür müssen wir alles tun ich
glaube die atomdebatte hilft uns nicht
weiter bei denen sorgen die die menschen
und die industrie hat sie sind da jetzt
so zurückhaltend r müller können sie
nochmal argumentieren also hat ja auch
große verfassungsgerichts urteile dazu
gegeben die verträge sind gekündigt die
leute sind gekündigt also sie könnten ja
auch ein bisschen vehementer sagen dass
uns das nicht rettet
das ist vollkommen richtig aber sie
haben mich eingeladen als präsident der
bundesnetzagentur da gilt eine gewisse
politische zurückhaltung in der tat alle
argumente sind vom wirtschaftsminister
habig ausgeführt worden die beginnen
sozusagen bei der frage der
grundlastfähigkeit dass es nicht das
problem was wir brauchen ist spitzenlast
das ist die frage wo die brennelemente
herkommen das ist häufig aus russland
und zumindest in der vergangenheit
gewesen ich verweise auf die aussagen
führender energie vertreter zb von rwe
die glaube ich unverdächtig sind die gar
kein großes interesse haben aber das mag
eine politische diskussion seien aus
sicht der bundesnetzagentur wir müssen
das problem lösen wir haben keine
stromlücke sollten sie nicht herbei
reden das ist nicht das problem dass
deutschland heute hat wir müssen gas
beschaffen da sehr
vorsichtige chef der bundesnetzagentur
das sind nicht argumente genug
der gegenwärtige chef der
bundesnetzagentur hat mit größter
eleganz absolut und dann haben die
aktivität verborgen dass er natürlich
ein früherer grüner minister es ist
deshalb ihn jetzt ausgerechnet die
kernenergie zu fragen das war auch jetzt
jetzt eine besondere pointe von ihnen
zurück zur sache in der tat wir haben
gegenwärtig keine stromlücke aber wir
haben auch klimaziele und
also die einige wenn er der chef der rwe
den herr müller gerade genannt hat aber
recht hat dann haben wir drei bis fünf
jahre diese situation auch vor dem
hintergrund der bezahlbarkeit von
energie und unserer klimaziele finde ich
macht es sinn über kernenergie zu
sprechen da ist dann zu fragen wo bekäme
man brennelemente her zum beispiel aus
australien ist das realistisch wie ist
der technische zustand der anlagen warum
sind denn die privaten betreiber der
kernkraftwerke in deutschland
gegenwärtig dagegen dass sie verlängert
werden weil
rechtlich dort die genehmigungen
auslaufen und dass natürlich jeder
betreiber fürchte das wird verlängert
und im jahr 2023 wenn ich charaktere ist
ein bisschen aber ist eine ernsthafte
sorge irgendwo ein wasserhahn tropft hat
man direkt die sogenannte störfall
debatte deshalb sind die zurückhaltend
wenn man das wollte ich benutze den
konjunktiv bewusst noch wenn man das
wollte dann wäre es eine politische
entscheidung in der notsituation für
einen begrenzten zeitraum und diese
debatte wird ja gegenwärtig geführt und
ich habe gesehen dass bei ihren kollegen
in der ard morgen eine umfrage wohl
präsentiert wird dass die mehrheit der
deutschen sagt ja wohl wenn es das klima
schützt und die energieversorgung
sichert dann sind wir für eine zeit
dafür offen das muss man ernst nehmen so
also jetzt können aber die bürger
vielleicht nicht so etwas entscheiden
weil ja auch ein echtes expertenwissen
braucht und deshalb ist es jetzt erst
ist ja vielleicht ganz gut wirklich mal
zu horchen ob die experten sagen dass
das eine klare sache ist und ob sogar
die betreiber und ehemaligen betreiber
sagen dass das nicht also sage den
betreibern und ehemaligen betreibern
habe ich ja bereits besorgen die haben
sich in eine andere richtung auch mit
ihren kapitalgebern orientiert sie
längst anders aus die anträge sind
gekündigt die leute sind weg frau illner
sie argumentieren gerade aus der
betriebswirtschaftlichen perspektive der
rwe hier geht es um unseren staat sodann
sind